sur ce plateau farid dems débat
fondateur du mouvement citoyen pour
l'algérie un cercle de réflexion
apolitique bonjour merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau
enfin les dames ce débat on parle de
dizaines de milliers de manifestants
dans les rues hier peut-être aujourd'hui
mais on a peu de chiffres finalement
est-ce que vous disposez d'informations
par rapport à la manifestation d'hier
autant de manifestations de masse qu en
est il exactement à terme de
participation
et peut-être aussi en termes
d'interpellations alors concernant les
chiffres du nombre de manifestants
malheureusement il n'y a pas en algérie
de d'instance me dire qui puisse se
charger justement du comptage mais c'est
vrai que tous les retours qu'on a pu
avoir notamment au niveau de notre
mouvement des gens des sympathisants qui
était sur place nous parle vraiment d'un
d'un regain de de participation
incroyable ddd foule tels qu'on les a
connus au début de cette révolution donc
là c'est un an de révolution algérienne
j'ai plus envie d'utiliser le thème
ferrat qui est galvaudé à l'heure
actuelle sachant que mme en irak
signifie juste mouvement là il faut
vraiment l'appeler tels que tel qu'il
doit être désigné c'est à dire
révolution mais c'était massif vraiment
massif où en sont les militants du irak
ou
du mouvement de révolution comme vous le
nommez emprisonnés
qui n'ont pas bénéficié d'une grâce aux
récentes on sait qu'il ya eu des
milliers de détenus qui ont été graciées
mais n'est pas de manifestants justement
c'est là où on se pose des questions sur
la vraie motivation du de l'exécutif
sachant que une des revendications
premières dès cette révolution c'est la
libération sans conditions des détenus
d'opinion quels qu'ils soient et à
l'heure actuelle cette revendication qui
est totalement légitime mais n'est pas
entendus il ya eu la grâce cette grâce
de tobin qui justement a permis à des
milliers de détenus de sortir et ça ne
concernait absolument pas justement les
les manifestants et les révolutionnaires
et et c'est ça le souci à l'heure
actuelle ne peut pas instaurer un vrai
dialogue
le premier point réclamé par par cette
révolution c'est la libération des
détenus d'opinion et justement ça pèche
un peu à ce niveau là vous parlez de
dialogue et d'abdelmajid they would
justement le nouveau président de madjid
tebboune appel au dialogue
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir justement un
dialogue entre les manifestants et les
activistes anti système et ce qu'ils
peuvent trouver un terrain d'entente
c'est compliqué sachant que de bouna
était en route c'est très bien il dirige
l'exécutif
enfin il est à la tête de cet exécutif
désignés par l'état marge à l'état major
l'état major qui s'est justement on va
dire habillé d'un personnage civile pour
mener l'algérie et c'était soi-disant
l'objectif de toute bonne lorsqu'il a
accédé au siège de président mais force
est constater que malheureusement il ne
tient pas parole
donc cette main tendue
n'est pas allée juste de parole n'est
pas de fait et c'est très compliqué de
discuter avec quelqu'un qui souffle le
chaud et le froid
donc on attend vraiment d enfin pas
grand chose de toute bonne mais au moins
deux de l'état-major des signaux forts
justement quoi comme signe fort parce qu
en un an il ya en tout cas me tire un
bilan il ya eu quand même des avancées
il ya quand même aussi des défis à
relever bah écoute et déjà quel point
celui que j'ai abordé dès le début de
cet entretien c'est à dire la libération
sans conditions de tous les détenus
d'opinion déjà ça sera un premier début
ça sera un signe fort d'apaisement de
cette révolution est là il est au
contraire ils sont en train de dents
prisonniers à tout va le monsieur de
boon va jusqu'à
vouloir déclarer le 22 février journée
nationale c'est le propre même du
cynisme voilà donc cesser on a du mal à
comprendre voilà sur coquelles sur quel
pied danser avec même pas nous mais
disons quelques bonnes à quoi joue-t-il
à l'heure actuelle une question
sociétale avec ce mouvement de
contestation
quel impact sur sur les femmes qu'est ce
que ça change sur la place de la femme
en algérie
ce qui est intéressant avec cette
révolution c'est que à l'instar de
grandes révolutionnaire de la guerre
d'indépendance tels que des femmes comme
madame bongo ali ou madame amrane où
madame dry fauveau madame hocine par
exemple quitter des grandes figures de
l'indépendance
force est de constater que justement la
femme les femmes algériennes parce
qu'elles sont plurielles ont continué à
prendre leur destin en main et ont été
fer de lance et de cette révolution et
je tiens à l'ordre
alors justement à dire que grâce à elle
et à la jeunesse
cette révolution perdure et je tiens à
leur rendre hommage
aujourd'hui pour c c'est un an de
révolution donc elles font partie
prenante de cette révolution je dirais
même que elles sont le fer de lance de
cette révolution ils sont l'essence même
de cette révolution
merci farine ce débat d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le fondateur du mouvement citoyen pour
l'algérie un cercle de réflexion
apolitique merci